welcome back everyone this is part 7 in
our series on contextual representations
we're going to talk about the Electra
model
recall that I finished the Bert
screencast by listing out some known
limitations of that model
Roberta addressed item one on that list
and we can think of Elektra as keying
into items two and three item two is
about the mask token the bird team
observed that they had created a
mismatch between the pre-training and
fine-tuning vocabularies because the
mask token is never seen during fine
tuning only during training and you
could think that that mismatch might
reduce the effectiveness of the model
item 3 is about efficiency the bird team
observed that the MLM objective means
that they only use around 15 percent of
tokens when they are training only 15
percent of them even contribute to the
MLM objective we have to do all this
work of processing every item in the
sequence but we get very few learning
signals from that process and that's
certainly data inefficient and we might
think about finding ways to make more
use of the available data
a lecturer is going to make progress on
both these fronts let's explore the core
model structure for our example we have
this input sequence X the chef cooked
the meal
the first thing we do is create X Mask
which is a masked version of that input
sequence and we could do that using the
same protocol as they used for Bert by
masking out say 15 of the tokens at
random
then we have our generator this is a
small bird-like model that processes
that input and produces what we call X
corrupt this is an output sequence
predicted by the model and the twist
here is that we're going to replace some
of those tokens not with their original
inputs but rather with tokens that come
out with probabilities proportional to
the probability generators and what that
means is that sometimes we'll replace
with the actual input token and
sometimes with a different token like in
this case of cooked coming in being
replaced by eight
that is where Elektra the discriminator
takes over
the job of the discriminator which is
really the heart of the electro model is
to figure out which of those tokens in
xcorrupt is an original and which was
replaced
so we train this model jointly with the
generator and a weighted version of the
discriminator or Electra objective
and then essentially we can allow the
generator to drop away and focus on the
discriminator as the primary pre-trained
artifact from this process
one thing that I really love about the
electro paper is that it includes very
rich studies of how best to us to set up
the electro model itself
I'll review some of that evidence here
starting with the relationship that they
uncover between the generator and the
discriminator
first thing is an observation where the
generator and discriminator are the same
size they could in principle share their
Transformer parameters and the team
found that more sharing is indeed better
however the best results come from
having a generator that is small
compared to the discriminator which
means less sharing
here's a chart summarizing their
evidence for this along the x-axis I
have the generator size going up to 10
24 and along the y-axis we have glue
score which will be our proxy for
overall quality
the blue line up here is the
discriminator at size 768 and we're
tracking different generator sizes as I
said and you see this characteristic
reverse u-shape where for example the
best discriminator at size 768
corresponds to a generator of size 256
and indeed as the generator gets larger
and even gets larger than the
discriminator performance drops off and
that u-shape is repeated for all these
different discriminator sizes suggesting
a real finding about the model I think
the intuition here is that it's kind of
good to have a small and relatively weak
generator so that the discriminator has
a lot of interesting work to do because
after all the discriminator is our Focus
the paper also includes a lot of
efficiency studies and those two are
really Illuminating this is a summary of
some of their evidence along the x-axis
we have pre-trained flops which you can
think of as a raw amount of overall
compute needed for training and along
the y-axis again we have the glue score
the blue line at the top here is the
full Electro model and the core result
here is that for any compute budget you
have that is any point along the x-axis
Electra is the best model
it looks like in second place is
adversarial Electra that's an intriguing
variation of the model where the
generator is actually trained to try to
fool the discriminator that's a clear
intuition that turns out to be slightly
less good than the more Cooperative
objective that I presented before
and then the green lines are intriguing
as well so for the green lines We Begin
by trading just in a standard Bert
fashion and that at a certain point we
switch over to the full Electro model
and what you see there is that in
switching over to full Electra you get a
gain in performance for any compute
budget relative to the standard Bert
training continuing as before which is
the lowest line in the chart
so a clear win for Electra relative to
these interesting competitors
and they did further efficiency analyzes
let me review some of what they found
there this is the full Electra model as
I presented it before
we could also think about Elektra 15
percent and this is the case where for
the discriminator instead of having it
make predictions about all of the input
tokens we just zoom in on the tokens
that were part of this x-corrupt
sequence ignoring all the rest that's a
very burt-like intuition where the ones
that matter were these ones that got
masked down here
that makes fewer predictions for the
discriminator
replace MLM is where we use the
discriminator with no sorry where we use
the generator with no discriminator this
is a kind of ablation of Bert and then
all tokens MLM is a kind of variant of
Burt where instead of turning off the
objective for some of the items we make
predictions about all of them
and here's a summary of the evidence
that they found in favor of Elektra
that's at the top here according to the
glue score all tokens MLM and replace
MLM those burnt variants are just behind
and that's sort of intriguing because it
shows that even if we stick to The Bert
architecture we could have done better
simply by making more predictions than
Bert was making initially
behind those is Elektra 15 percent and
that shows that on the discriminator
side again it pays to make more
predictions if we Retreat to the more
burt-like mode where we predict only for
the corrupted elements we find that
performance degrades and then at the
bottom of this list is the original Bert
model showing a clear win overall for
Elektra according to this glue benchmark
the electorate team released three
models initially small base and large
base and large kind of correspond
roughly to Bert releases and small is a
tiny one that they say is designed to be
quickly trained on a single GPU again
another nod toward increasing emphasis
on efficiency for compute as an
important ingredient in research in this
space